CBS News chief Washington correspondent
and Face the Nation anchor John
Dickerson is with us from Washington now
John good morning to you how do the
president's comments affect the North
Korean situation morning Jeff you know I
he double it was so interesting
yesterday he doubled down in a sense he
said his remarks should have been
tougher but in fact he pulled back a
little bit on Tuesday the president said
all the North Korea had to do was merely
threaten the United States then of
course they immediately threatened the
United States and nothing was done
nothing was planned to be done so in a
sense he drew a red line and they walked
right over it what he said that was more
specific yesterday was the United States
will respond if they if they attack Guam
now that's more specific and more sort
of traditional and what you would expect
from a president so while he said he
should have been tougher he in fact drew
a new line that was a little bit more
realistic
John president Trump has been so
critical of former President Barack
Obama's redline that he drew for himself
in Syria isn't President Trump in fact
creating a new challenge for himself
with this rhetoric that's right I don't
on Tuesday he improvised according to
reporting that with that comment that
basically there would be this
catastrophic response if North Korea
simply threatened so that was a red line
which they immediately they threatened
Guam and so now he's put a new marker
out there
Secretary of Defense mattis was more
skilled in the way that he threatened
North Korea he basically said stop doing
things that will lead to the end of your
regime that allows some cartilage in the
in the relationship so there's no
mistaking what Secretary of Defense
mattis was saying but he also doesn't
put himself in a corner if they do
something specific that crosses the line
that he's drawn John you also had some
really strong words from President Trump
directed at the Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell let's listen in they
said Mitch get to work and let's get it
done they should have had this last one
done they lost by one vote for a thing
like that to happen is it disgrace and
frankly it should
happen the president needs McConnell to
get his agenda through Capitol Hill
what's he doing here he does well it's
both counterpunching and a little bit of
blame-shifting counterpunching is that
the majority leader said recently that
essentially the President had set
expectations too high that his
expectations were too high remember in
health care the president said more
people would cover be covered that their
coverage would be better and that the
whole thing would cost less everybody
who's been working on health care knew
that was impossible but the majority
leader argued basically that the
President had had set expectations too
high and this was the president
responding to that but the blame
shifting a little bit too was the
President had come to Washington saying
he alone could get health care passed
now that it has failed he's putting it
on the Senate and we'll see if that
actually gets any results the margins
are quite narrow that Mitch McConnell
has to work with there John General John
Kelly is rounding out his second week as
chief of staff he started with a mission
to bring some discipline and to
streamline communications in the White
House are we seeing that some discipline
but obviously this week the president's
remarks have been quite improvisational
so he may be managing down but he still
got a challenge in managing up John
Dickerson in Washington John thank you
very much